You can't spit on a sidewalk.
If you live with somebody for seven years of the opposite sex
are considered married. It's
the common law married act.
I just made that up.
In Virginia, it's illegal to have more than five
women in a house
because it's considered a brothel.
No oral sex.
So if you grew up in Virginia, you probably went to Jamestown.
Which was really weird and apparently is sinking right now.
Robert E. Lee Day was the same day as Martin Luther King Day.
I'm gonna pronounce how you would say it
and how we say it.
So there's Buchanan.
Which you say as: Buh-cannon. There's
Botetourt which you say as Bot-uh-tot.
Staunton which you call Stanton.
Buena Vista which is Byoona Vistuh.
Norfolk is pronounced Nor-fuhck.
We got a Wayne Newton award for 'Breakout Artist in Roanoke'.
because Wayne Newton apparently lived in Roanoke for maybe like a hot second.
Dave Grohl is from my hometown of Alexandria, Virginia. That's our claim to fame.
Across the street from my house, there was this barbecue place.
And that's where high school Jared Leto used to work.
The Virginia flag is pretty intense.
It's a woman warrior stepping on this, uh, this other dude.
What is the story on that really?
Basically, a woman standing on top of a dead tyrant. Death to tyrants.
When I was 5 or 6, I had a pet cow named Blackie that chased my brother up a tree.
and was later killed by wild dogs.